we are back and when our next guest
discovered her son's drawing Talent she
wanted to Foster that gift but as she
quickly realized access to the Arts
often falls through the cracks so she
took action and now she's running a
thriving arts program for all the kids
in her community not just yourone which
is amazing and that's why we call her a
rad
[Music]
[Applause]
human all right everybody from
Brooklyn's Red Hook art project also
known as rap everybody say Hello to
Tiffany
so we hello how are you hi
everyone so we were talking about your
your son you notice he had you know it
was very talented art but he didn't
really know what to do with that right
no yeah I mean my children were always
into the Arts but as a young mom giving
birth at the age of 14 years old and not
having access to the Arts myself I just
didn't understand for me it was like son
daughter you need to know how to read
and do writing I didn't understand the
whole coloring Basics I just didn't it
didn't didn't resonate with me I just
didn't it wasn't until you know he drawn
on the walls I was like somebody's
trying to tell me something what do I
need to do yeah and first of all don't
draw on my wall exactly that part um but
art classes weren't an option right no
art classes wasn't an option for me you
know living in low income Communities
going to low income um schools doe
making a lot of cuts funding the first
thing they do is pull the Arts and for
me that's another way to silence a child
another way to silence a person when
they don't have access to these things
some people are introverts they don't
like to speak out loud right so they
like to draw and paint a picture around
what they trying to say you know so not
having access to that felt like death in
itself yeah no Arts is the literally the
reason why I graduated high school
because I had to make a certain average
to be able to participate in the art
program so that was what really drove me
cuz all of our brains work differently
um you know and how we learned so where
is Red Hook art project today right now
Red Hook art project is an asset in our
community we do a lot of work in our
communities we support students with
building art and music portfolio so they
can audition for specialized high
schools and colleges wow um we also
fight food insecurities you know just
during the pandemic we were able to put
Community refrigerators outdoors and
bring over like $1.2 million into the
neighborhood to make sure kids have
access to food and also Mee art class
wow that's incredible yeah you're a
great Mama you're like a mama bear
taking care of all the kids yeah it's
important so create creative writing
programs y'all do that as well right yes
creative writing is a huge part of our
program because again you can't make art
and not be able to express what it's
about right when you're creating your
own art shows you have to be able to
write about it write your descriptions
write your medium you know just write
what it's about so I think even in
school when you're writing out your
essays to go to college you have to be
able to do creative writing
writing is a b of what we do andri like
my daughter she blossomed through the
organization because she used music and
writing as a a tool she graduated high
school a year early and salor and then
went into cosmetology oh God more
because of her being able to write and
see herself honestly that was me as a
kid as well as soon as I started writing
and it music it it was therapeutic and
it gave me a certain level of confidence
that I could achieve anything I think I
believe in that as well so what do you
feel like your organization's impact has
been on the community our impact is
ensuring that students have a safe
vibrant space to be they have a voice
that we meet each of them where they are
at um and they have access the impact is
access uh a lot of us myself growing up
didn't have that or didn't even
understand what access or resource meant
so I think the impact is meeting people
where they're at and giving them that
access that they deserve we all want
thing opportunities and a safe place to
be yeah you want to be successful in
whatever that means for you and your
children yeah absolutely well we love
your passion for the kids like not just
your kids but like other kids that's
incredible that's what makes you so rad
um Red Hook um and for the Arts we love
what y'all are doing for the Arts in
general and so does our season long
partner pilot pin makers of friction the
go-to race pin of the Kelly Clarkson
show and they want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly just like you so
they're going to give Red Hook art
project $5,000
wow
and I think it's I think it's so
important what you're doing and I am
from a similar neighborhood like before
I moved like even to Burleson like I'm
from Fort Worth Texas as well and I'm
from the same neighborhood we did not
have opportunity as well so I now have
the means to help out kids that were me
so I'm Gonna Give You 5,000 as well so
that's
10,000 cuz this is helping out me as a
kid too I think it's really cool what
you're doing it's really special and
setting them up for success to give them
that edge is
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home